oh hi everybody and we are here with
Chris Baker who is back in the game life
Studios after a long absence I can be
back very very nice to be back III is
coming up and we wanted to talk to you
guys but what our predictions are for
this this most crazy of video gaming
shows so what's going to happen this
year one new consoles there won't be any
yet none absolutely none no it's not
it's not going to happen the economy is
weak they weren't going to do it anyway
even if the economy was great yeah they
weren't making money you know off
existing games because it costs so much
to develop for the current generation of
consoles so they love the consoles they
have now everybody's sticking with them
number two might not be any new consoles
but I definitely think Sony is going to
show a new version of the PSP maybe it's
gonna have a touchscreen it's probably
not gonna have a disk drive it's
probably just gonna download games yeah
i think sony has done okay selling the
actual PS PS but they haven't been
selling the games that you play on it
and that's where they make all the money
so this is kind of a last ditch effort
to appeal to people with games to maybe
you know counteract the piracy we've
been seeing with the PSP and to compete
with the nintendo dsi and the iphone
both of which are big threats to Sony
right now now we don't have a lot of new
you know not going to see new consoles
but number three I definitely think
we're going to see a big focus on
accessories this year and I think the
biggest accessory is going to be the wii
motionplus which the knock on the wii
controller has been that it's not
precise enough and this adds a much
greater level of precision to you know
tracking your movements and it will be
interesting to see how people respond to
this do they do they think okay this is
a game changer this is going to let us
you know see a bunch of new games or
will they say yeah it's slightly more
accurate wii controller that's all it
needs to be Baker and hendo already
changed the game maybe we're going to
see Microsoft and Sony unzell motion
controllers to Nintendo already changed
the game they did what okay now all
these pendo needs is to continue its
current level of success and wii
motionplus is
one of the ways in which they might do
that I definitely I think we're going to
see content from Nintendo this year
aiming at hardcore gamers if they know
they disappointed the hardcore I mean if
they you know if they just shown punch
out or sin and punishment last year they
could have avoided all of these all
these internet flame is and all these
problems that they had at the very least
you know greater focus on hardcore
friendly games maybe you know a big
release that just gets all the hardcore
is in a frenzy certainly we're going to
see a whole lot of sequels I mean
obviously this is video game industry we
see a lot of sequels anyway but number
for prediction is definitely economy
causing people to rely on old franchises
and and really try to go for sure fire
surefire hits sure I mean there's always
been this knock that the game publishers
play it safe and keep their games cheap
this year the watchword is panic they've
been so many games of the last holiday
seasons that cost tens of millions of
dollars to make and didn't earn a
fraction of that back we're going to see
you know a lot of games you know that
the company's wish they had green
lighted two years ago we're going to see
a lot of games that just sort of iterate
on existing assets you know the way the
guitar hero will just keep putting out
new games with just new songs in the
existing game right but even even beyond
that like how halo three ODST I mean
that's not a sequel to Halo 3 that is
using the halo 3 engine to try to build
a new game that costs less money to make
you know the fallout three of the GTA
expansions expect to see more of that
sort of thing as well okay and our final
prediction is I mean my prediction is
that people think that III is going to
go back to the old III and then it's
gonna be just as glitzy as it was three
years ago I don't necessarily think so i
think a the economy and be just you know
i know i don't think it's gonna be like
this huge big thing i think it's really
just going to be maybe a little bits of
morning and i will unrelated note I'll
predict that III has always been about
you know a forum to show off the big
triple-a releases you know at a time
when frankly I think the most
interesting
stuff is the free browser based on my
Mo's the little indie games that guy
makes in his garage I predict those will
get short shrift Eddie through this year
and a lot more people will notice their
absence than having news post bigger
this is all well and good this
even-handed industry analysis we've been
doing which should make some crazy
predictions like you know a new console
from Sega or something like that
September 9 2009 yep new Sega console
absolutely definitely uh I don't know
there will be a new game from the shadow
of the colossus team man my fingers
crossed like I certainly hope that
happens I can't wait to play this game
and it's like come on guys get it out
there we'll go out on a limb what are we
going to see um my going out on a limb
is that saying that hardcore gamers will
be happy after nintendo's press
conference there's an outside shot that
maybe they will be I will see ya
you